well I think one thing it shows is that
the corporations uh corporate
investigation teams being outpaced by
its own journalists because if you look
at how the corporate investigation
handled the initial complaint back in
May and it took them seven weeks to
actually even contact the presenter they
weren't able to follow up the phone call
with a phone call the emails wasn't
responded to they weren't able to stand
things up here we've had an allegation
that's come into a journalist they've
been able to verify the phone number
they've got hold of the messages they've
spoken to the individuals concerned
they've tried to get hold of the
presenter to get a response they've
spoken to their lawyers it's all
happened very quickly and that's what I
mean the BBC essentially being outpaced
the director General asked about this uh
earlier this this morning about whether
or not there would be other allegations
there were other allegations he couldn't
answer that but it does look like you
know it just demonstrates these things
can be done actually that these things
can be done quite quickly I mean
obviously we've only got the BBC's word
for that at this stage but they they are
saying very much that they feel that
these allegations do stack up they stand
up and they've tried to get a response
from the presenter concerned and I think
the second thing obviously is it's
adding more mud to the situation whether
or not it is a criminal offense or not
we don't know just how nasty those texts
were how intimidating they were for the
individual we don't know the exact
circumstances of what was said at this
stage but it does make it more difficult
I think as Sadi was saying for this
thing too just remain as it is as a
status I think for for a while it was
thought well maybe now there'll be a
pause the BBC pausing its investigation
there'll be a pause while the police do
their investigation and maybe not much
would happen and yet here we are there's
another twist it's quite a Different
Twist to the one we had yesterday
because of in a sense the one yesterday
was more in the BBC's favor here was the
young person who was featured in the Sun
article saying that nothing had happened
that there was no criminality there was
nothing untowards using their lawyer to
um to to make that statement but in some
ways even that has caused problems for
the BBC now because when uh the director
General was asked well do you know
whether the presenter had contacted the
young person about this maybe even paid
the lawyers fees the director General
wasn't able to answer that question and
big questions as well around why the
director General hasn't actually spoken
personally to the presenter at the
center of this so yes it just adds more
mud more difficulty for the BBC in what
was already a very difficult situation
yeah question marks remain over any
criminality in what's been unfolding
over recent days Jason that's up to the
police to decide they are looking at
evidence there is no police
investigation happening at the moment
but in terms of this BBC presenter and
conduct I mean we've not seen these
threatening messages BBC News hand they
will I'm sure pass them on to police to
decide if there's anything for them to
investigate when it comes to those but
it's the conduct
of this BBC presenter that's now being
called into question BBC News saying
they have contacted this presenter and
his lawyer but have got no response
um that is going to be the unfolding
story in the coming days isn't it Jason
as to whether this presenter is named
and whether there is any way back for
him
I think there's a bit I mean this is the
thing that's there's been quite a big
silence now for quite some time
um you know there's not been a denial
there's not been a you know a partial
denial even around around this uh the
you know the first allegation and now
the BBC is saying they're getting Stony
silence over this one as well you might
not expect them to react immediately
um but I think that pressure will grow I
think the pressure will grow for some
sort of response
um and it you know does it remain as a
suspension and the BBC have already
worried about the way in which this is
impacted on other presenters uh you know
presenters who've done nothing wrong
who've been named libelously on social
media so there are a lot of things that
kind of hang around this this allegation
um and if there's if there's one I'm
sure there will be people looking for
others as well you know so you know is
this is the beginning of a proof of a
kind of uh a way in which this presenter
has been behaving over a period of time
with other people and whether there's
there are more allegations of so
obviously the director General was asked
about that and wasn't able to answer
that question and didn't want to answer
that question at this stage so we don't
know whether there have been other
formal complaints against this presenter
at this time that's not being revealed
and I think whilst there is so much
uncertainty around this story and still
so much not even mean made absolutely
clear about the things that have been
put out there by the Sun newspaper not
all of those things have been made clear
it's exactly what the BBC knew it
exactly what time I think it gets harder
and harder for them to to do nothing if
you like which is I think what they
might have done had things stayed static
because they might have just said well
it'd be you know the police have told us
to pause this investigation at this
stage you know that's what we're going
to do I mean they might still stay with
that line but I think it gets harder